in new polling Senator Kirsten Cinema of  Arizona  formerly a Democrat no more is polling  13 percent in a hypothetical three-way  race against Ruben Gallego and Kerry  Lake Kirsten Cinema only 13 very  interestingly if you remove Cinema as an  independent candidate and just do Lake  versus Gallego it's still just one point  separating the two suggesting that  Cinemas support is made up roughly of  half of Democrats half by democrats and  half by Republicans which isn't a huge  surprise if leaving the Democratic party  was a calculated gamble for Cinema to  avoid a primary challenge within the  Democratic Party by a progressive it  doesn't seem like that math is going to  work out for her we have to wait and see  but so far looks like a very bad  decision